hey what's up what's up
john delony here with the dr john
deloney's show where we talk about your
life
your challenges the stuff going on in
the world around you the stuff going on
in your heart and stuff going on in your
mirror we talk about everything on the
show
right we take your live calls
we take your uh emails your instagram
follow me
at john dalone um i've never said that
before on my own show it just feels
weird
but we're in the world of the internets
kids and so it's time follow me at john
delony
so today is a special interview
episode of the dr john dolone show one
of my best buddies here
at ramsey solutions is my good friend
rachel cruz
she is super fancy super famous
she's dave ramsey's daughter and she
recently wrote a book and so this was on
my list my 2020
list it's called know yourself know your
money
most of these interviews when you see
somebody who just wrote a new book
is they have these points and they just
go down the points and then the
interviewer's like oh
wow no way and the interviewers never
read the book
and the interviewee acts surprised at
the questions coming like
oh i didn't think you were going to ask
that and then they just make it up right
this interview is super not that this is
me chatting with my friend we talk about
this book
but we talk about the stories behind the
stories in this book because i want to
know
what's it's like growing up
thinking about wrestling with money and
you
are your dad is the public voice about
money in america
right what's it like getting married
under a microscope what's it like
having these tendencies having these
things that you just default to
that are kind of embarrassing right so
we get into it
this episode is just gonna pick up right
in the middle of a conversation
between two good friends um our families
are friends
she's awesome i'm mediumly awesome so i
hope you enjoy the interview with my
good friend
rachel cruz here we go so every one of
these interviews
you go through a series of and for those
of you who don't know this is insider
baseball but
um when you go when you've got a book
out and you go through
like the points and the like here's the
things you want to make sure everybody
gets from this
okay sure so big
tell for this show is just like 11
listeners max
right and a couple of them my mom has
different radios on at the same time
so it boosts the thing yeah there's only
a few people
on this show so for those of you who
don't know
i am really picky about what goes into
my head and i read a lot
and so this book is on my 2020 list as
books that are real good and books that
i went through
and thought that's not something i'd put
together in that way
and i'm pretty snobby about the books i
read and i i remember texting rachel and
said this was actually really good and
you read like a super early copy before
it even like went out no it's
it's it's real good because i wanted
your input it's on my like hey this is a
really good book list
thank you and so um i just thought man
instead of talking about this book and
like
snapping a picture on instagram and
being like dude bro read this like why
not have you here right this is so great
that you're here and i appreciate
me and the 14 listeners are so happy so
happy so happy to partake
so part of this thing is we get on this
this list of things and i told you
before
i'm not i came up with my own questions
because
we're gonna get behind the scenes so
that's what you're saying though is like
you get these talking points and so
it's this i've had the same interview
close to probably 300 times
that's right so i'm i'm so dialed in and
now we're at 301
off script yes i'm prepared okay you get
30 seconds to do your onscript pitch
tell us about this book and then we're
getting way off into the woods
oh like i can really talk about it yep
okay yeah so
for 10 years now almost a decade over a
decade now
i have been talking about the how-to of
money right so how to budget how to get
out of debt how to invest how to
refinance how to save how to give how
how but if personal finance is 80
behavior and only 20
head knowledge the how-to is kind of a
small part of it
you actually have to do it and change
your behaviors with money
and so you know all of this was in my
head also because i was kind of on this
journey myself probably four years ago i
remember taking the enneagram
i read the book the birth order books
i'm a middle child witchcraft voodoo
continue
yes you really think so oh my gosh all
of that
oh i'm into all of it and counseling all
of it but i was having all these like
self-aware
witchcraft voodoo and science all in the
same thing
science is almost voodoo sometimes right
you think i'm just kidding
no no all of this stuff so anyways for
myself and my
journey i was realizing a lot about
myself and i remember thinking okay
not that i've arrived by any means but i
do feel like i was a better wife and mom
and friends i was just way more in touch
with
understanding how i function and why i
do the things i do yeah so then i
thought
well how does this apply to our money
because i don't talk about that i talk
about how to budget and how to get out
of debt
and it like sent me in this black hole
john so out came the book where i was
like this is it but
but understanding why you handle money
the way you do is so key
because i think a lot of life problems
masquerade themselves as money problems
it's not really budgeting problems it's
not really a problem that you and your
spouse
can't do a budget together or you
overspend or you're deeply in debt
there's a lot of other stuff going on
and so getting to those root issues
was really important so it's everything
from your childhood your fears your
personality your tendencies your dreams
all of it and that's what makes up the
book why we do the things we do with
money
walk me through you i love that analogy
walk me through your
got a black hole here and i'm thinking
this as an author
because the the the the cheater part of
an author is i'm going to write
something for somebody else
and this book came the other way right
this is like
i'm looking in the mirror and this is
scary yes so you're standing on the
precipice of this
black hole and you have
something unique is you've got like a
public figure family
that is all about money and then you've
got your own money stuff and then you
find yourself five
ten years married in which so you're
bringing somebody else's money stuff all
in the same place and you're standing
over this precipice and you're like
this is gonna we're going ready to go
down a rabbit hole walk me through that
like as i'm entering it what i'm seeing
what i'm discovering well i think
money is so much more emotional than i
ever gave a credit for
okay like i again the principles and
everything we teach
are vital like you have to have those
yeah you have to have those
but i was starting to ask myself
questions like okay rachel if nobody
sees this purchase do you
still want it why am i even buying this
or
rachel are you buying this to feel good
yeah are you stressed
are you bored um i mean it was that it
was those kind of questions i'd never
really asked myself because i'm like
because in my head if it's in the budget
i'm not going to get it right i can get
it and it's fine once and i agreed on it
and all that okay
but now i'm sorry so then it's like this
whole new round we've been talking a
meeting the other day
two weeks ago i came home from work
because i have this like
loft box is what it's called so it's a
subscription to ann taylor loft
you're welcome and you get new shirts
like every week that you send back
you just wear once and back so the show
that i do because it's on video
yeah because it's like a subscription so
the fact that i'm on video so much i'm
like i don't need
all these new clothes but i do have new
looks and all that so
long story short they sell the items
really inexpensively if you choose to
keep them so some of the items i do keep
so i
brought home like four items last week
and i'm walking through the kitchen
with you know clothes and i see winston
and i pass them in the kitchen
and i just made up the story in my head
automatically that he's he's
judging me he's way more low maintenance
than i am and i have a closet full of
clothes and here i am buying more
clothes and even though it's in the
budget
he's thinking rachel why are you why do
you keep spending money on clothes you
don't need new clothes
and i just and i like walked right out i
was like babe i bought four more shirts
they were all less than ten dollars but
i bought them i just need you to know
and he literally was like okay baby last
thing in his head oh he's like that's
great i was like okay i kind of feel
like you were judging me and he was like
what
and i was like i'm sorry but like i'm
aware of that now like before i would
justify it in my head and not even go
there emotionally but now
i'm allowing myself to ask those
questions does that make sense yes
so through that whole journey like
through all of that and then seeing how
you were raised going back and talking
to mom and dad like
it all was coming out that was the black
hole i was in
that's a lot it came out as a book yeah
yeah yeah most of us come out of those
black holes with like
jail time or like a new addiction
yeah liver problems and you come out
with a book so way to go
okay so um i want to talk about a couple
of the things that you talk about in
this
book and obviously you know the show
for those of you who don't know rachel
and i our offices i mean our desks are
right
next to each other um in this show we
go down the rabbit hole on a daily basis
right get into the messiness of people's
lives
so we're one of the chief neon red signs
over the last
year has been this this pulsing
fear fear fear right and there's been
it started with we're all going to die
you know 13 to 20 million of us are
going to be dead in the next few months
right yeah you and you and i were on a
plane in manhattan when broadway's shut
down
we weren't in a plane we were in a hotel
john thinking we're gonna be shut out of
this island
and stuck here yeah do you remember that
one of the moments that one of like the
stamp moments of my life was when
the pilot turned around and said they
closed the airspace we can't leave oh
that's right and i remember thinking
oh this is when the movie starts right
like
yeah but me and ken were walking down
down
broadway when they came out of the
theater and said broadway's closed until
further notice and i remember
looking each other like whoa okay so we
were there so
like that night in hotel i remember
thinking i've got to get out of here
because if they shut the they're talking
about shutting the bridges and tunnels
which obviously they didn't do
but that time we had no clues mid-march
and manchester united it was right it's
mid-march 2020 right
and so in the epicenter right so
people are like hoarding toilet paper
you couldn't buy a deep freezer for
seven or eight or nine months right
now bullets are essentially currency
right
um people are exhausted and scared and
running
in this book you talk about i wrote them
down here's some fears you run against
me talk about money but they're way
bigger than that
right lack of security not realizing
your dreams the unknown external forces
past mistakes
ending of like your parents um
what do you how do you walk people
through this idea of
dealing with their fears and you talking
about money but they're way bigger than
that
yes well and i would love your take on
this john because you're a doctor and
i have some yeah whatever but you got a
book some uh yeah
i don't have the letters after my name
well dr chip dodd
is someone that i really talked to for a
while on the phone when i was talking
about this subject because i love his
take on emotions in general
but i loved what he said he said that
fear is
can be seen as a gift that fear is your
body's literal response that you are in
need of something
okay so when you can identify that fear
and name it
put truth around it put safeguards in
place that's what you want now when it
goes to paralyzing you can't make
decisions it goes into anxiety
all of that like that's the unhealthy
side we don't want
but the good the good fear of what you
could see as a gift
is if you are one of the americans that
you know live
paycheck to paycheck 78 of them 40 of
americans couldn't cover a 400
emergency in cash and so if that was
your if that was your reality
in 2020 and you were furloughed or laid
off
that fear of financial security or
insecurity
rises in you and so what you can do is
take that fear and say okay what is that
fear because yeah that's a legitimate
fear if you don't have money in the bank
and you lose your job
of course you're going to be freaked out
and fearful or if you think like i need
to have
meat because they're going to close
they're going to close the grocery
stores right right right like whatever
that fear is so so
in that money specific situation i want
that to be able to be your
your red light that says okay the way
i've been handling my money isn't
working it's not going to work if
there's a pandemic it's not going to
work if i'm laid off it's not going to
work if a health crisis comes
okay what would work having money saved
being out of debt not owing anyone
anything like putting these principles
in place the how-to of money that we
talk about so much
okay so letting that fear be somewhat of
a not your only motivator because i know
fear is not a terrible motivator i've
heard that
but at least let it be your signal i
mean it's literally your body's response
that you are in need of something so
what is that need
and what can you do around it so that's
kind of what i walk through with these
money fears
so help me with mine so i actually have
a few of these
so i have a particular background
like i have a particular family story
and
i've been an idiot i've always had a
scheme with how the money's gonna work
dude i have been all over this gamestop
thing had i been
10 years ago it's so sad all my schemes
would have paid off
um and external forces right they're all
just going to come and we're going to be
trading coffee and bullets
and whatever hides or whatever the thing
is help me with mine
how would you walk somebody through
how would you take me from these fears
like dude they're coming for us
we're not gonna have enough i'm such an
idiot from the things i've done in the
past
how would you walk me back from that
well i mean i would
in the book i talk about each one
specifically so the external forces one
focusing on the things you can control
because we can wring our hands well what
if the meat runs out or what if
this person gets elected into office
what if what if but those are things
that we can't control
right but there are things we can
control in our life we can control
our income when it comes in what we
choose to do with it we can control
our work ethic we can control the people
we hang out with
like there are elements of our life that
we can control and so
that's a big one for that external
forces because i do people just watch
the news ring their hands and think
we're all going to die
and i'm scared to do anything and that
fear becomes paralyzing
okay we'll stop there and say okay well
what are the things that we can put in
place that we can control
yeah and focusing on that so that would
be one uh
the parents think yeah i don't want to
end up with my parents
it's a big one i mean walking through
that my counselor said this and i loved
it he said
we're not here to bash your parents but
we're not here to defend them
we're here to tell the truth ah okay so
what's the truth like what is that and
so for you to be able to go back whoever
that is i mean i heard stories people
said you know i grew up
basically it felt like a door a dirt
floor and had to buy the
two two day old expired bread at the
grocery store because we couldn't afford
anything and i
never want to be like that i never want
money to be like that for me i want to
i want more of it right or i talked to
one girl and her parents
you know everything looked great on the
outside it was like the typical family
right great house great cars dressed
great
all of it and she was like but we were a
mess as a family she was like we were
all miserable
gotcha i didn't she is so she said to me
she was like i just want to drive a
honda civic for the rest of my life
yeah because they had all these luxury
cars and everything and i laughed and
that's so funny but
now that's not the reality for her she
doesn't need to drive a honda civic not
to end up like her parents
but to say okay what were the things how
was it how was money talked about how
was it
how was it placed the value system of it
did it have control over me because
money is powerful yeah yeah
what do they say money sex and power
are like the three deadliest sins like
about where people say that and i love
that because it's true but money is one
of those like
it takes you to a level if you're not
careful and so i think being able to
identify
your family of origin and how money was
viewed how it was handled
okay tell the truth about the situation
and then what things are going to put in
place for that not to happen
i'm in control of what my tomorrow's
going to look like right
sagan i'm in control of what my what my
tomorrow will look like right
to an extent but not fully right i don't
know you're the psychologist
well i'm i'm saying like it's when
i don't stop and acknowledge that story
or
who don't do interviews for a living i
just do an underhand pitch with a giant
red bouncy ball and she just completely
swung and missed she was just like whoa
we're playing ball and she missed so
john you did i don't know i'm scared so
speaking of fears
um but no but but so a lot of folks walk
through life and don't realize they're
replaying a script
right and so when you recognize it the
second and you mentioned this
a second habit or a second tendency we
have is to go to war with them
right with our old parents who are
trying to figure things out in the 70s
or 80s or not whenever they were
and that ends up with a lot of bloodshed
and not a lot of things
are solved right by just going to war
right right
um or we gloss over and pretend it
didn't happen and that doesn't help
either
but then yeah at the end of the day i
get to choose and what tomorrow's going
to look like
yes that's right that's right um so
i don't know how vulnerable you feel
like being today but this is the show of
vulnerability
so what did
my greatest money fear yeah is that
you're gonna ask yeah not so much
that's cool but more what did what
mirror work did you have to do to
acknowledge it
um i would say my
one of my moments especially during
covid was i woke up
it was probably may-ish i would say
in the morning and i just had this
moment of like oh my gosh
are we gonna be okay like it was to the
point that working for home was
happening and it was the all the meat
shortage was happening
all of it and it was like and we're
thinking okay what if
our 401ks bottom out never return like
what if amazon prime doesn't ship in two
days because they're saying it's three
weeks now and
and like what if what if what if and i
had this moment where i realized
wow i and i was saying it out loud
because i went to bed and i was saying
something i was like babe i was telling
winston like
like what if all this just goes away
like what do we do
and he laughed the first thing he said
because it's always his answer when i
ask that question he's like i will
landscape yards
yes we're gonna be fine yep it's gonna
be fine uh
and number two he was like babe it's
fine like we're good like i was so
irrational almost
uh okay and i realized that i had placed
a lot of value in security and safety
and money
without even realizing it so like it is
wise everything we talk about right
being out of debt
not you know having an emergency fund
funding retirement setting yourself up
well
but that safety that spectrum can go to
an unhealthy place
where it becomes so much about that that
the moment that foundation possibly is
shook like
it made me think who am i like am i good
like if we lost everything like
oh my gosh okay so take me to that
moment it's okay
what does that feel like because i i
i've worked
so hard for
my job my the blessings in my life
given via you know my family and my
parents and they've worked so hard like
all of this
and my and my personality can easily
it could become everything and so i have
done intentional work to leave
everything like this
okay like i've seen i've even told
friends
i'm like if like crap hits the fan and
everything's done with
i don't want you to have to put me in a
padded room at vanderbilt because i
literally don't know who i am
gotcha like that's my goal in life okay
so
obviously i don't want crap to hit the
fan ramsey we love ramsay wanted to go
on because it's helping a lot of people
but like i know my i'm a three on the
enneagram i know you think it's voodoo
but i can become i mean that can easily
become my world
so i just have to be very aware so it
was that moment where it wasn't
necessarily my job that was freaking me
out the moment it was my money your
identity
and i never thought my money would be
that deep of a security
but in that moment it was and so it just
made me recheck it was convicting yeah
yeah mm-hmm
okay switching gears um
some people thanks rachel for spilling
your heart out no it's a time so now we
need to change this is so great
yeah we're done no more of that
counseling we're done with that all
right
um so a lot of it's it's almost been a
split
um and and i hate to bifurcate things
this way i hate to barbell it right it's
either or but what i've heard a lot is
people are
this has been the worst year ever
compounded and compounded and compounded
and then there's this also quiet
whispering which is
this has been the best year for me and
my family ever
right like financially we just went to
work and it's been awesome
someone got laid off and so i wouldn't
get another job it's paid me more money
my marriage is better because we had to
figure stuff out
my marriage like the the seo data here
like people are googling divorce divorce
divorce is
just got like a trend line right
some of that falls into this middle
ground which is people have made
decisions they've made mistakes they've
screwed stuff up they've done things
that violate their
set of their core values the way i would
say that and we
just beat the crap out of ourselves when
we do that when we find ourselves
violating
our one of our core values we say
something we didn't mean and i just
wrote some things down right
when you text somebody you shouldn't
have when you call an old boyfriend we
lie about it when we
promise ourselves that we are not going
to eat sugar anymore
or drink anymore or we're going to work
out whatever these failures are these
violations right
in the book you talk about money
mistakes
i don't know a person this year that has
not
made money mistakes like we've got this
set of rules in our house we've got a
budget in our house we have nothing in
our house
and they look back and go oh my gosh
like what have i done right
how have you experienced
and by the way you said money mistakes
i'm calling them failures and violations
and you're like money mistakes you're
got such a positive spin on it that's a
mistake yes um
how have you experienced these mistakes
this year
uh personally i mean it's more fun if
you tell us personally but
yeah you're talking to bajillions of
people yeah what was funny though is i
so i wrote back to the book john will
play
i wrote the book before my before my
third kid
before charles came because i wanted to
have a full maternity leave so
the manuscript of the book was not due
until march
of 2020. well i wrote it and ended it
october of 19. okay so there was like a
big chunk of time that that
manuscript just set before it was due so
during covet i was editing
the book which was such a different take
right you're like in this weird world
and
it was this pre-world before covid and
then i'm sitting here and covet
editing the book and so for me a lot of
my mistakes came
the spending chapter i talk about why we
spend the way we spend
and that was huge for me i even edited
some of that to put these stories in
because i was like i literally
am sitting here during a pandemic buying
off amazon more than i ever have in my
life right and i'm justifying every
purchase
because of its price right it's just 15
bucks it's not a big deal yeah
it was just that that that because it
feels good right and we know this like
if there's a dopamine hit that happens
when you spend and so
for me oh i was caught in that so much
and not even because i necessarily was
stress i was more bored at times
it just felt good it was exciting
something exciting going on that there
was me a package showing up at my front
door
i'm saying like a friend showing up yeah
yeah for me
to unpack it and it's and i forgot
yeah so that it was a lot of that kind
of stuff it was like that medicator
and because it felt good so i had
similar
where i would show up i'd go to the
hardware store for a quick thing and i'd
show up with a
like sheila they've got deep freezers
and i got another one she's like we have
one
john and i was like i know but you know
just
in case because of a scarcity mindset
yeah and she would ask like so what do
you think's gonna happen
and what are we gonna put in there and
my head's like well you know
you know you just start it's just
nonsense right
um so one of the things i've experienced
over the last decade if you will is that
people
often talk to themselves not often all
the time talk to themselves in ways they
would
never let somebody else talk to somebody
else right
it's unbelievable how we abuse ourselves
internally
put us in in the mind of someone who's
unlike this show has a successful show
just gets sad and writes a book about it
right just experiences some things and
can crank books out
how do you handle negative self-talk
like you get these purchases
and you're like i teach people this for
a living
right like me i teach people how to be
well and how to have good marriages and
then i
say something stupid and then i go to
bed and i'm like good job marriage guy
right and my wife's like how about you
sleep in the yard right
how do you how do you experience a
self-talk and how do you
work your way through it that's a good
question um
i tend to sadness i've learned
is like the emotion i hate the most okay
don't be sad all right and i will do
things
in order not to be sad everything's fine
so i probably could sit in those
emotions more than i do but yeah i mean
i think
yeah the moment i realized oh yeah this
amazon package or this or that or like
oh uh or you just catch that one glimpse
and
glance in your husband's eye and he's
like yes
you're judging these purchases he's like
uh
yeah i mean i would say the yeah the
negative self-talk of
oh you did it again of course you of
course you were
of course you did it's almost like that
and then but then i just go to justify
it because i don't want to feel that
so i say okay you go to straight line
are you ready for this yeah
i go to the budget and i said well it's
in the budget and i just can justify it
because just because you what matthew
mcconaughey said this and i appreciate
it just because you can
oh what did he say it was so good just
because you're
able isn't necessary
okay or something like that yeah yeah
which is a big question like that's like
oh my
wow that's it that's it so we can but
should we
yeah do i need it no i don't i don't
need another necklace that's
eight dollars and nine nine cents from
probably china like
i saw that um i saw a great
instagram thing that was like how
does 495 plus 850 plus 717 at target
equal 137 dollars like when you get to
the end they just met up yes
yes yes so what how do you teach
somebody to recover from that
shame that mistake that like what an
idiot dude
um that you're self-worth who you
are right this is like very brene brown
but it's true like you are not the
mistake
like you're you can make mistakes that's
not who you are right
so it's that level of grace and i feel
like when you i find people that have a
tough time
extending grace usually have tough time
extending it to themselves
as well okay so it's kind of back to
what you're saying like the way we treat
ourselves we wouldn't always
treat other people like that yeah so and
then give me the other side the one that
is
constantly over gracing themselves the
enabler that's probably what i would
call them almost when you enable
yourself like
the constant justifier right the
justifier yeah yes oh yeah it's in the
budget it's fine you can afford that
just 15 bucks
so give us one question if you're an
over justifier and
again it's i love this books it's about
your money but it's so much more than
that so
it is i shouldn't have texted that
person went into justification
right old like my old boyfriend
just reached out uh my wife doesn't need
to know about or my husband doesn't even
know about that it's all good
right or i wasn't gonna eat sugar but
it's just a birthday party it was just a
christmas thing i don't want to be rude
to kelly she brought us whatever what
i just bought this i know it was the
budget it's fine what's what's a
sentence
a justifier can ask himself
um there's no right specifically yeah
specifically around spending money
i think it would be the question of why
simply like why did you do it
was it to feel good okay was it because
you're bored
yeah okay well why are you okay not
being bored because
i don't want to sit alone with my
thoughts i'm saying like asking that
was it you that said it it's like the 4y
level who was that that talked about
that
ask why four times and you can get to
the root oh okay okay
so i love that yeah yeah so keep digging
take the credit i thought i was going to
credit you for it was that you
no super wasn't me i'm always more
sophisticated than that but yeah i'll
take it
so so why why don't you like sadness and
that sounds silly but
why do you avoid it uh it's the one
emotion that makes me uncomfortable i
don't like it
i don't like people being sad um
i don't know because my counselor would
be like rachel we've paid
many sessions for you to work on this
and i can't come up with my house and
we're talking
i know you paid for my summer vacation
that's right
uh i don't just it makes me
uncomfortable more for the other person
too
okay i think i can feel i can put on a
level of sadness but i also don't want
to stay there because there's a level of
me that's like pull yourself up by your
bootstraps
uh okay and so sadness falls into an un
uh
what you really love okay if the healthy
part of sadness yeah yeah yeah
but and so i often find folks who
fall into a what i call the the
peacekeeping trap
want to make sure everybody else is okay
right
yes and i want to make sure everybody
else isn't sad it's that i know that
funny i'm like you can be mad you can be
angry wealth conflict
you can be annoyed you can have all the
emotions but like if you're sad i'm like
oh let me fix that please don't be sad
like movies this is us the tv show why
people want to watch
a sad show on a tuesday night or
whenever it comes on
i watched like three episodes of it i
was like no i'm going to spend an hour
of my life watching like this sad
thing on tv absolutely not so there's a
hundred percent challenge
that i'm to have rachel back on the show
and we're going to talk about all the
stuff she does watch and then we're
going to
we're going to analyze that it's so good
i do love
i love that show too okay so yes
youtube videos bye oh my gosh and i
think we're credible
if you were to um if you were to take a
lot of acid
and then look at rachel's youtube search
history
your brain would explode and i know
they're going to edit that out
but i'm just telling you whoa
whoa rachel's one of the wonderful
people that you see
every day and they look like they've got
their life together and they're so kind
and they believe everything on youtube
and my brain can't
i can't do the math on it it doesn't
work all right last thing we're talking
about oh i was in a deep conspiracy in
covet
and and winston and christy wright she's
still
super there by the way we're like why
does this one guy that has 69 views on
youtube
know this stuff but no one else does and
like
because no one else will report it
exactly
so great he's the only one if there's a
dude filming a youtube video like from
the trunk of his car
on like a like a at a state park
rachel's like this guy he's super nose
do you have a bug out bag do what like
you would have a bug out bag though do
you
i just call it common sense oh
like that's a different level then
here's the way i live my life
things are probably going to be okay
almost all the time
but they might not be like when the grid
gets shut down so just be what do we do
all those things right what do we do and
it's so awesome is that i buy deep
freezers and you buy necklaces that's
right
you would think i would have when the
grid goes down i'm gonna sparkle
all right so the last thing here is this
is the tendencies okay
so you talk about money tendencies which
are our default settings
and um i kept hearing tendencies
as identities or stories we tell
ourselves or stories we tell ourselves
about ourselves okay
so i picked a few tell us real quick
about the saber spender or the free
spirit and the nerd
okay so these spectrums just a few of
them you've got several tendencies yeah
for sure yeah okay so the extremes i'll
say are unhealthy and then i want to
pick them apart psychologically
oh man and you can help me with them got
10 minutes strong we got 10 minutes we
got it
[Music]
spinner saver yeah i mean like if i gave
you 100 bucks your knee-jerk reaction is
to spend it or save it like that that's
an easy one somewhat to
to understand and then again the
extremes are unhealthy so if you spend
everything you make
you're going to be broke if you save
everything you make you're a hoarder
and probably not very generous so like
it kind of goes on those extremes
uh free spirit nerd is the that's a
classic ramsey-ism
so usually around budgeting or managing
money are you more of a free spirit
don't like details and that's okay it's
not wrong
if you go to the extreme of that it can
get bad because you're not
being intentional you're choosing not to
budget if that's what you're choosing to
do and living
off that main emotion the nerd
is enjoys the budget they they're good
with numbers they love excel they love
details that's naturally their gifting
the extreme side of that is they become
legalistic and there's no room for error
anything because they just live and die
by the budget
so when i think of savor or spent versus
spender
like or when i think of save over
spender or
free spirit versus nerd it feels like
rational versus emotional or strong
versus weak
and you characterize those let me put
this way
i have been around relationships i've
i've walked alongside folks who
weaponize
either one of those things right yes yes
like we would be so much better if
he wouldn't fill in the blank or if she
would just fill in the blank right
so the free spirit sounds so romantic
and loving life
and the nerd feels like you know fun
ruiner.com and
the how but in the financial world which
is funny is the nerds more praised
the free spirit i feel like is the one
that gets like the
yeah exactly making that funny though
but like i love that example that you
just said cause i'm like yes
and it could be the opposite people are
like oh yeah
like i'm really good at a budget like in
my world people praise those people
you're the free spirit like you're
irresponsible yeah you've got you just
ruined everybody's life
yeah yes so how do you there's often a
fine line between
identities and excuses right this is who
i am
right this is just i'm this way versus
that gives me a pass to sorry honey i'm
just the free spirit
like i know but that's all you spent 500
on supplements
that conversation has never happened in
my life
like um i'm just a free spirit hun and
you're the nerd so
how do you help folks walk back the
difference between identity versus
that's just an excuse
i mean i think there's a level of
responsibility you have when you're an
adult so like you don't
get to you just went straight to like
um that's ridiculous you grew up like
seriously i'm like you but no you're
right yes like for the free spirit like
you have a responsibility you don't get
to just go do whatever you want because
you're right
you're crazy for a therapist by the way
just like do it
right good job but like you have a level
responsibilities free spirit and you
also have the level of responsibility as
a nerd not to push everyone away in your
life
and to love people well and give grace
so like there's responsibilities on both
ends
that we have so to move to that middle
it's a level of awareness
that i can tend to be you know one or
the other which right neither one
neither one is bad right or wrong it's
not true so like you can be okay and be
a free spirit or nerd um but that
healthy medium is that healthy medium
because i can be a free spirit but
choose to budget because
when i budget we know where our money's
going we get to go do fun things
we get to go on vacation because we're
setting money aside like and that's the
balance then
for the free spirit for me yes
absolutely yeah and then pushing the
nerd i don't know nerds i'm a free
spirit so
the nerds out there their balance is
just to enjoy
yes so i i i love
this the language you put in the book is
helpful for me
i immediately go to how do people hurt
each other with these labels
right and as i went through it i kept
thinking
it was fun because i'm looking at myself
like i'm the free spirit
and i instantly want to be like yeah i'm
not a nerd and as you mentioned
nerds do things like pay their bills and
nerds like
like buy cars with cash and stupid
things like that and make money
blah blah blah yeah exactly and free
spirits have fun
and free spirits enjoy their life right
unlike us
so uh no like us like us yes but you
both need each other
fun we are not sad we are fun
and nerds aren't funny there i i love
there's a whole other conversation all
right so the last question and we got a
few minutes left
you mentioned a few times um that
about counseling what is something
you've learned about yourself
one of my missions with this show is to
norm like
going spelunking into your heart and
into your past and
then um finding ways that you can
change your relationships and change
your your life in a positive way
sometimes just a little bitty thing
sometimes it's big things uh
two things i'm very selfish okay
my needs and wants like i like yes
they're the same
they are or you're asking no i'm saying
for a selfish person needs and wants are
the exact same thing
yes yes uh and in the same talk back to
the sadness thing i can avoid
pain i will avoid pain i can avoid
tough conversations if something
sad something that should make someone
sad happens
parenting marriage whatever you fill in
the blank i tend to
check out and say it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be okay
and by doing that creates that that
level of
unauthenticity okay not vulnerability
because i don't allow myself to go there
in a relationship sometimes so when you
over over the years in counseling you've
probably had to practice that
yes what give some language to what it
feels like when you do
um when you practice sitting with
someone who's just sad
do i practice sitting with someone just
that no like like
yeah so i mean engaging my feelings
would be to be able to verbalize and
communicate
exactly what i'm thinking and feeling
without filtering okay and i even say
that out loud
okay i don't want to do this because i
don't want i don't want pain for you i
don't pay for me
but i'm choosing to have this
conversation because i love you
and i want a better relationship and so
here are the places you've hurt me
here's the you know the sadness the fear
the anger
that i was feeling like just being able
to lay it out
okay and be okay with that because
here's the deal too this took many
hundreds of dollars in counseling
you can't control what the other person
does with that that's right and so being
able to go into those conversations
knowing i can't control you i can't
change you
but for me to be able to tell the truth
with what i experienced
is a that's a huge cleansing step and
and when you do that though you know
this but like you're opening yourself up
to be known and that person can choose
to reject it yeah
so that's scary but you do it for the
for the relationships that are worth
fighting for because those are
exhausting
conversations so like the people in my
life that are worth fighting for
my family it should just be a few people
my marriage yes
a few of my great close friends yeah
that i'd probably put the energy i'm
just kidding you and sheila
rachel never has these conversations
with me she's like oh
oh hmm and then she moves on it's fun
everybody
it's fine yeah but there's like the yeah
the people that you're like no i will
fight for that relationship
so i will go there in places like i
don't like to go but i will
in order to be known so
paint me a picture of your physiology
while it's happening
what does that feel like it's weird i
mean it's been years so i've
practiced it i'm calm now okay and i've
learned though
my voice i get bigger with like
when people get insecure they either
turtle or they go big
and i go big my voice will get loud i'm
leaving my body posture i mean i i get
big
no no i watch myself because when that
starts to happen i can feel it go so
then i have to take a few i like
okay calm back down my language my tone
my speed yeah all of it so
that so for whatever it's worth your
show's always like this is it like one
big counseling session
your therapist is awesome and here's why
as soon as somebody can make a
connection between
their physical response and their
emotion
that's that is the key right because
then i know
oh wait a minute they're not making me
feel this way
this politician isn't making me feel
this way this is my body responding to
the fact i'm scared
or that i'm nervous or that i'm sad and
so what you just did for folks listening
all 14 of them is give them like
oh i start octaving up my voice and then
i want it right and i start
and that may just be a signal that i'm
scared or i'm uncomfortable
or that being sad in my family was a
no-go
and so i don't want to go there and when
i start feeling like we're entering into
sad space
then my body's like whoa rally the
troops right and whatever that looks
like or
i'm the uh i'm the opposite i turtle up
and say bye
yeah and shut off i get withdrawal
that's right yeah
awesome okay oh well that's deep enough
for today rachel
john thank you i'll can i venmo your
accounts
150 whatever your fee is she um just
sent a message into my ears she's like
the spaghetti john the spaghetti so this
we gotta wrap this
this uh mom spaghetti she's also a
rapper um
all right so we we end every song with
your favorite lyrics
and i actually have a song
y'all again rachel works over in the
office with us and she sings this song
all the time always going
um but she said hey i want to do two so
you do yours and then all
i have the one i printed off that you're
always just singing in the office
okay i'm not a music person so when
john's like you gotta bring lyrics i was
like what so then i googled taylor swift
of course this is one of my favorite
songs and i've never actually read the
lyrics i don't think
it's such a favorite i don't even know
the words please i i hope they're so
revealing and offensive here's the one
part of the story that i do love
and if i'm in my car i can just yes is
this it
uh what's the name of the song oh here
we go dear john
i think it's about john mayer or john
a little bit of my us weekly vibes okay
i love us weekly and the fact that she
wrote a song and titled it dear john
makes it amazing or it could be about me
but whatever
you're an expert at sorry and keeping
the lines blurry
never impressed by me acing your tests
he had tests she didn't ace you catch
that sean it's brilliant
all the girls that you've run dry have
tired lifeless eyes because you burn
them out here's the best part
but i took your matches before fire
could catch me so don't look now i'm
shining like
fireworks over your sad and empty town
i mean what was the fireworks
brilliant katy perry yeah and then
i think it was before katie's time
though yeah i'm trying
dear john she's talking i see it all now
that you're gone
don't you think i was too young to be
messed with the girl in the dress cried
the whole way home see taylor she said
look i gravitated towards the sad lyrics
you went right to the sadness your
therapy's working but the best was the
matches and you
instead of lying on fire i'm no
exploding
so and as we wrap up today's show the
other song that she sings
all of the time in the office there's a
perfect song
for rachel cruz um by the way as we wrap
up get this book it's awesome
um i'm not even gonna give you the
the title i know it or the it will you
sing it every single day
so i can't okay yeah um i'm not even
gonna give you the the author of the
song the the writer or the performer
um or the name of the song i'm just
gonna
read these lyrics as she reads them as
she just
i mean just lets it go all the time it
goes like this
i hopped off the plane at lax with a
dream and my cardigan
welcome to the land of fame and excess
whoa am i going to fit in jumped in the
cab here i am for the first time
look to my right and i see the hollywood
sign this is all so crazy
everybody seems so famous my tummy's
turning and i'm feeling kind of homesick
too much pressure and i'm nervous
that's when the taxi man turned on the
radio and a jay-z song was on
so i put my hands up they're playing my
song her hands are going up right now
the butterflies fly away i'm nodding my
head like yeah i'm moving my hips like
yeah i got my hands up and they're
playing my song and i know
i'm gonna be okay because it's a party
in the usa it's a party in the usa
can i add an asterisk to this absolutely
have you seen
the clip of the taxi driver
re-saying the lyrics and it's like it's
a girl named miley
she took my ox cord and like didn't you
like the whole thing
it's so good ladies and gentlemen i have
no idea what she's talking about this
has been the dr john deloney show
[Music]